hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well
seeing how we are at the end of
Nickelodeon Monday I can safely say that
I am not the least bit happy why because
I have to review what many considered to
be a double order of bullshit with extra
crap and a side order of debt sheet
fast-food abomination simply known as
good burger based off the hit sketch
performed on the kids show all that good
burger was an attempt to take one line
welcome to good burger home of the good
burger can I take your order
and some he'll turn that into an hour
and a half movie welcome again burger
home of the good burger can I take your
order
no but you can take this and shove it up
hard the film stars Kel Mitchell
reprising his role as head butt idiot
fast-food attendant who works at the inn
appropriately titled good burger it also
stars Kenan Thompson which is weird
because he never really starred in a the
good burger sketches but who the hell
cares let's just get this ass burger
review out of the way all right so it
starts off with our protagonist ed
welcome to get a burger
oh well good I can hear you already oh
oh god
I see I see you I wanna stay here with
you we love you egg come with us good
Wyatt why why would happen
ah welcome to good burger home of the
good burger can assist stop stop I made
a minute
so it turns out that opening was just a
dream but unfortunately the rest of the
movie is and rushes out the door because
he's late to work this is bad because
nobody else at the restaurant knows how
to take orders which really pisses off
huge angry Robert walls just give me two
good burgers I had up to here with good
burger hey I don't need this either
cameo in Batman so we see and rushing
down the street as he chips into some
girls playing jumper up drags one of
them down the street accidentally steals
a woman's baby collides with some
basketball players mixes up the
basketball with the baby as the baby is
dumped into a basketball hoop you know
what I'm gonna need another minute
so and finally makes it to work only to
find that there's another restaurant
called mondo burger being built across
the street that could be dangerous
competition but their boss isn't worried
good burger has been here for over 40
years and nobody is putting good burger
out of business
Bogota what are you doing
is there just really no movie that
you'll say no to hey did you read the
script you know I could have been a good
movie my guest is used in some sort
contract or something it probably went
something like this
Abe the president of Nickelodeon says
you had to do the good burger movie and
he can't do that it screws up all my
arrangement sorry Abe you're under
contract
Tom can you get me often role types I
can't do it come on
we get to wear the little hat and
everything so we then cut to our other
main character jester who's in a
classroom being taught by a terrible
brother oh jesus no being taught by
Sinbad with an outfit made of wrapping
paper and a haircut modeled after a
Blowfish
his personality though that's a little
harder to figure out I was just thinking
my brother Wow
why would this man give us a test on the
last day of school before summer start
chromatin why because the money Never
Sleeps right on my mid seventies early
eighties black panther hippie
environmentalist blaxploitation flower
child brother Dexter thinks he's out of
school for the summer which means he can
spend the rest of his time partying but
there's a change of plan when he
accidentally crashes in the Ronald
McDonald here see when I left school
today I think I was gonna run to you
this summer I don't think you're gonna
run into me I mean just ran into me like
this you and show me young man you in
trouble isn't mr. weed fishing it wasn't
my fault
see this nut on some rollerblades he
skated into my vision sight and I
couldn't see metal designs were wrong
here no what's that car cost me no do
you know no my $2,000 car
$22,000 and that's just the base price
Oh me Travers like I don't regarding my
driver's license are not seriously but
quit the shuttle no no when they put it
in my hand you'll have a driver so no I
know you don't have no insurance D yes I
hate to do this young man I hate to put
a black man in jail I'm at the call
police right man yeah hey dude you ain't
got I'm just a kid it's like they knew
they had no story a little joke so they
just told the actress to make some crap
up off the top of their head
it's a villanelle movie wanted somehow
why should I talk about who cares with
the kids film is elegant you have to try
my god they're still going this will be
handled with just one line of dialogue
O'Shea I need a job
why is that so hard finally a different
scene no no write down and then pink we
should argue just get on with it
oh I never thought that would be my call
back to reality I'll take it so Dexter
has to get a summer job you see one
sentence that was so much easier as he
applies at the mondo burger where
everyone dresses like they're at an
eighties gym from now on your life is
mondo burger you can forget about your
friends you can forget about your family
because Kurt is now both your mother and
your father but Esther sadly doesn't
seem too vivid get booze out of my face
loser or nag about to push me a little
too obvious to me yeah extra crispy
please I hope said in I live ain't
watching so he goes to a place where
he's clear lack of talent and absolutely
no experience will do him well but you
said you wanted nothing on it yes when I
expected a meat patty did a meat patty
is something you said nothing fizz is a
meat patty something or nothing don't
you philosophical with me kid it's not a
kind of movie we're all born to die sir
so edit Dexter finally Mia as Dexter
Vince's close one more good shake good
good keep them coming
I'm dude don't you think you've had
enough don't tell me what I've had
enough shake I'll tell you when I've had
enough second I'm sorry I didn't mean to
snap at you chase it down with some
fries so ed tries to convince his boss
the detector should begin the job ain't
good hey mr. Bailey this guy needs a job
can he have one no end of the movie bye
come on mr. Bailey it really needs one
you can do fries Otis does fries yeah
but look at him how much longer could he
possibly live not thinking show me I'm a
bug gonna all right so Dexter is hired
on as one of his jobs is to make
deliveries in I'm not kidding the burger
mobile come on I'll take you for a spin
Oh
but all is not well as the ruler of
mondo burger comes in to intimidate our
heroes the second we open our doors good
burger goes in the grinder what's up
with this kid it's like someone put
sting Frankie Muniz and Ben Stiller in a
blender it's kind of surreal I'm head
huh dad you better watch your butt man
okay
so mondo burger does open up to probably
the most overblown fast-food restaurant
opening ever even Planet Hollywood
doesn't get this type of opening I mean
what are they expecting to see in there
oh my god their fries honest-to-god
fries so they take a look at one of the
mondo burgers to see why their business
is doing so well
huge how do they do it
my god they use actual meat no raccoons
at all
so MS Dexter if he wants to hang out in
ah do you think you get me to a hospital
I think I broke my ass okay yeah I'm
convinced now that a pagoda wasn't
supposed to be in this movie he just
wandered onto the set throughout the
costume and start walking around bumping
into people they were just like hey he's
not hurting anyone just keep them in the
movie
you ain't Godfather man show some
dignity as other Dexter become more
acquainted with each other it discovered
that they have a complicated
relationship I don't like you you get
that boo yay what I'm great nose boy hey
Winnie blue Edie boobity boobity boobity
boobity boobity stop it
Louie blooby blooby blooby blooby blooby
blooby blooby blooby hey anybody be shy
buddy booby booby booby booby booby
booby pay winning movie deep Oh buddy
buddy blue Charlie blue buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy doing
everybody'll in Vega laughs my god I
just realized what this is this is
Dante's 11 level of hell
he just did write about cuz he found a
too scary for people to comprehend and
lo and behold and I'm not just douche
bag with unconvincing dreads we'll put
grapes in his nose and constantly shout
blue petty blue petit blue petit blue
petty and it will be called the 11th
level of hell Dante then wet himself and
cried in fear so turns out ed brings his
own special sauce that he made himself
as people pass the round they realize
it's pretty good I personally don't
trust anything that looks like a blended
Fraggle but everyone else seems to
as they marketed to the people raising
their profits again but Dexter makes ed
sign a contract that lets Dexter have
80% of all the money that they make on
the sauce presumably high as a kite that
agrees and continues to be shed upon by
the people he thinks he knows and loves
well here you go ed you get to keep $13
wow that's almost $14 huh Wow
that is the stupidest thing I've ever
heard plain and simple but Edie being a
sentimental guy ask Dexter if he wants
to hang out on the rooftop and just look
at the Stars yeah apparently
Ed's deep what kind of problems do you
have
most of them sided when I was a little
kid that's when my dad left me and my
mom must have lived in 15 places since
then wait wait a minute are you actually
trying to have a moment are you actually
trying to emote an emotion other than
disgust I remember the last time I saw
my dad I was seven years old I'm sorry
it's a little hard to get into this
moment well one of the last scenes we
saw was I think I broke my ass that
makes a little tricky I give up I'm
going on and I enact him I'm really
going home
fuck this movie the next day they get a
call to deliver a special order to the
holy other celebrity they could afford
in this movie feel hungry take the food
take everybody just please don't do any
rapid so the gift shake is order and
even managed to get a little endorsement
from him oh good this is back in the
days when is endorsements actually meant
so order tomatoes on this good burger I
don't see no tomatoes well manga
consider yourself tomato huh
wow that's pretty badly and making
Shaquille O'Neal look like a good actor
meanwhile mama burger is just please the
good burger sales are suddenly rising as
it just steams their PVC spaces good
burger is still in business well what
are we supposed to do about it
our burgers are already twice the size
of an sceptic may I recommend firing our
photon torpedoes at the restaurant
kitchen yes sir make our burgers bigger
bigger foot they're already
but there's still the problem as to how
does not that special sauce and created
so they decide to send in a beautiful
woman to seduce end and get his secret
ingredients if anyone can get the sauce
better pet she can okay I don't wanna
know how she gets the sauce out of IDI I
just assume that's private
oh I felt that
a while so Roxanne tries to seduce ed
but our attempts are fetal against a
thick wall in this you are so hot
oh I often sweat it work huh my god
Hallmark cards are funnier than this so
you hungry yes I am hungry but not for
food I'm hungry for you oh well well I'm
not edible
so it agrees to go out with Roxanna Oh
hold up well somebody give aid some
direction back there give him a cookie
or something can he come on this ain't
a-gonna not a dishrag
he's the funniest thing in this movie I
don't even think it's supposed to be
there
so Hank goes out with Roxanne as Dexter
also asked to have his coworker named
Monique but I think he's doing that
because he secretly wanted I mean look
at them they look exactly alike I think
that some closed doors here that need to
be opened so we Roxanne tries to get
intimate with n but this turns out to be
extraordinarily dangerous and she
discovers that love hurts even more than
she knows abuse to women is funny
after Roxanne gives up at the hip love
burglar and in Dexter start to suspect
foul play as they think mondo burger is
using illegal chemicals to make their
food larger so they disguised themselves
as on Jesus really you're gonna go the
drag route what what why if I didn't
know better I'd say you were from a
subpar childish sketch comedy show after
they worked their way inside our two
heroes find out mondo burgers dirty
little secret people no it turns out
that they were using illegal chemicals
but our heroes are caught as the head of
mondo burger decides to do the first
logical thing in this movie have them
both committed finally it should have
done at the beginning of them so the
two-part taken idiot interrupted as they
try to figure out a way to escape but
while that's going on the mondo burger
people partake admission implausible as
they try to sabotage ed sauce making
everyone who eats it incredibly sick
let's go guy here guys you woke up eight
ape says he's gonna call the police but
the mondo burger decides to have him
committed to I somehow doubt that was
very hard so our three nut jobs are
stuck in a mental institution and have
to figure a logical way out that
solution start a synchronized dance
number of course look at them go you
know for the mentally disabled they sure
do have good on-the-fly dance
choreography I'm really impressed and as
your sense of impossibility may have
told you don't guards start dancing to
queue up let's go over here and dance I
think it's our job to stop
out-of-control stuff like this but
pretty sure if we let our guard down
once nothing bad can happen oh so that's
why we're not paying well okay so they
steal the keys get out of the room but
how are they going to get out of the
actual good way one of the local crazies
decides to help them out
you know for as bad as this movie is I
do like its sudden burst of cruelty but
how's a frail old man like a pagoda
gonna get out of there and that's the
last waivers on it's okay I landed on
the fat kid they all tried to make it a
good burger to stop the customers from
getting sick as a summer turns into the
end of the Benny Hill show
yeah that's nice crashing the car breaks
some teeth and danger people's lives but
at least the good burger will stay open
but and in Dexter make it in time ins
and starts an old lady from eating one
of the burgers this needs to be censored
so ed and Dexter explained about the
sauce and stopped all the orders just
before they hatch a plan to break into
mondo burger and expose them from the
liar's they are but first this Joe I
need a hot Jacuzzi
you know what fuck it so they figure out
a plan to get into the mondo burger and
get rid of all their chemicals gee I
sure have a hungry for some rold gold
pretzels right now how do you expect me
to get up there oh it's easy you just
jump on a burger jump on the fry and
then you hop on a cup and then shimmy up
the straw
what is his American Gladiators what is
that a joke so they break into the mondo
burger and try to intimidate the rest of
the cook mama never had one of these
with the electronic numbers we always
had to turn that nigeria buddy why would
you I wouldn't come any closer
stand back man I think that's real catch
Oh No how are they gonna go around the
restaurant covered in ketchup and
mustard that's just silly oh that's
right smack your ass just show us with a
likeable character you are you little
troublemaker Oh how's it gonna scruff
this time oh and you nincompoop but I
bet it'll all work out in the end
somehow it always does oh it looks like
all those chemicals are causing the
burgers to explode
that's so out of the ordinary how dare
call it wakey you people had better run
faster there's no telling what others
state antics could possibly follow
always they character nobody lies do you
think you'll get his comeuppance in the
end well that all depends do you want
cheese on that oh oh oh it looks like
God has finally spotted you for making
jingle all the way Sinbad good luck
trying to clean that up whoo what a mess
well it looks like our two lovable
skanks and finally come out on top they
were scary moments at times but was
there ever any doubt that they'd make it
in the end
howdy don't think so so after all this
wild crazy and totally off-the-wall
antics how else can they possibly end
this movie besides saying the classic
line welcome to good burger home of the
good burger can I take your order you
certainly can it
you certainly can this is crap it's got
awful good burger good god what a lot of
shit it's like if shit could shit and
that shit good shit and that shit could
shit that shit to raise money to put
together a team of filmmakers directors
of steaming flaming vile a shit my
advice is leave this order among keep
you forever
and never look back as long as you live
or even after you die because that way
at least God knows you're trying to do
better I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
about this contract man
all right what did you say we just
forget you don't want to be partners
well no see is it because I'm black oh
honey Joe